here are some celebrities who wrote in
their Memoirs some interesting
experiences they had with other famous
people so Melissa Jonah revealed that
when she was on Sabrina the Teenage wish
she was experimenting with drugs in real
life and she alleged that Paris Hilson
once offered her drugs Melissa wrote
that she was once offered Coke by Paris
Hilton but that she turned it down in
Danny Trejo's Memoir who revealed that
he met Charles Manson in prison and that
Charles Manson actually hypnotized him
when Danny was 17 he was arrested and
brought to Los Angeles County jail and
Charles Manson was also being held there
so Charles Manson told Danny and his
other jail mates that in exchange for
his own protection he would guide them
through a meditation that would get them
high without using any drugs and Danny
said that it had actually worked and
that he actually felt high and like he
had just done heroin and in Elliot
Paige's Memoir he wrote that he'd
actually been in a secret relationship
with Kate Mara while she was in a
relationship with someone else he said
he went to a party at her and her
boyfriend's home where she openly
flirted with him and Elliot said that
her boyfriend stood close by not giving
it a second look and that he and Kate
ended up going on several dates but also
that he knew he was setting himself up
for heartbreak because she was still
with her boyfriend